no more planning
just doing
[Music]
hey welcome back to your weekly ticket
we have great news for Jurassic Park
fans like me
sam neill who played dr. Alan Grant in
the previous Jurassic Park installments
just confirmed that he and his co-stars
Laura Dern and Jeff Goldblum will appear
throughout Jurassic world Dominion not
simply in cameos he'll confirm this with
Yahoo movies UK saying we're all the way
through the film Jeff and me and Laura
Jurassic world Dominion is set to hit
theaters in June of 2021 all right
you're gonna love this one
cuz Jason Momoa is playing Frosty the
Snowman in a live-action pic for Warner
Brothers and Stampede ventures mm-hmm
the Aquaman star will embody a CGI
frosty in the hybrid CG live-action film
David Baron bomb is set to write the
script Momoa will also produce Frosty
the Snowman alongside DC Comics Geoff
Johns Hill next be seen in the reboot of
Frank Herbert's dune Paramount Pictures
has won the distribution rights to the
United States first Billy Holladay the
Billie Holiday biopic was offered for
sale at the Cannes virtual market with
four minutes of test footage that
started a bidding war lee daniels will
be directing producing and co-writing
the script on the legendary jazz singer
the film focuses on holiday being
targeted by federal agents via an
undercover sting operation aimed at
prohibiting her from singing her 1939
song strange fruit if you've finished
watching everything on your watch list
well don't worry because I have comedian
and movie buff Jay Washington to help us
with a pic Jay what do you got for us
today
so kill my pig is something that a lot
of people may have not have seen but
I've heard about it's the culmination of
14 movies within the DC Animated
universe in his Justice League dark
apocalypse war like I said the
culmination of 14 films that comes down
to a giant climactic battle where the
Justice League faces off with the
formidable Darkseid and after an
unfortunate turn of events have to make
their way back and
right everything that went wrong you
have an incredible voice cast as you've
always had throughout this rosario
Dawson Jerry O'Connell matt ryan is John
Constantine who I don't want anybody
else to be my Constantine from here on
out but Matt Ryan and Tony Todd as
Darkseid which that voice alone should
give you nightmares but I try to do that
voice myself even the time let me say
how many times I've told people my
victim just in my own voice just to have
a Candyman X thing but I strongly
suggest parents I get it we have raided
our comic book movies and your kids
sometimes like to watch a little
violence you might want to prepare them
for this one because if your child
starts screaming you know what happened
oh my god let me tell you it gives
really really violent I know I watched
it and for the first 15 20 minutes I was
texting people like oh you got that Wow
what
so yeah Justice League dark apocalypse
war is my recommendation what is your
scale
well first off I I do not crush enough
DCE you like animated features I've seen
flashpoint flashpoint is dumb it's the
start and this is the end
oh no way I saw the first half you saw
the beginning your is to finish it kale
just just just go through as you could
tell it with all the comic-book stuff in
part to stuff behind me I'm the host of
the mad Titan podcast so I get you
caught up on Marvel and DC TV show of
the movies yes Justice League dark
apocalypse war ok I think I just have to
now even like maybe I'll give it a shot
ok cool well my recommendation is well
recently we lost the great Fred Willard
and so I wanted to give you a
recommendation of one of my favorite
Fred Willard roles and that is his role
in Best in Show now if you don't know
what Best in Show is it's about it's a
mockumentary about a bunch of
contestants going to the Mayflower
Kennel Club dog show and they're all
competing to be Best in Show
he plays one of the commentators he's
hilarious there's one scene where he's
like why don't they can went on the dog
contestants
we're like a little Sherlock hat and a
little Sherlock pipe and like dress up
and look like little characters and it's
it's just great he kills it it's a great
time if you miss shits Creek Catherine
O'Hara is in there so that's great
highly recommend you'll have a great
time so that is my recommendation well
thank you so much Jay Washington for
dropping by it and giving me my
much-needed conclusion to the DCE you I
mean yeah there's 12 movies in between
you might want to catch up on I don't
know if you got the time throughout all
this and we just stand at home and
they're only like an hour and a half so
they're not super long cuz we're you
stout a two-and-a-half-hour movies and
stuff like that hour and a half in and
out and this one is our to have movie
you're gonna be like oh my god oh no oh
my god
not not not cyborg oh you just don't
feel all the emotions I love it I live
alone it's gonna be great alright man
thank you so much preciate you available
to watch at home on Friday first cow go
to window you okay
history isn't here yet and it's coming
that Amy it's time again
[Music]
taking on our own tongues to travelers
on the run from a band of vengeful
hunters in the 1820s Northwest dream of
striking it rich but their plan to make
their fortune on the frontier comes to
rely on the secret use of a land owners
prized dairy cow the Kelly Reich art
directed film is certified fresh' with a
96 percent on the tomato meter also
available to watch at home on Friday
money plane you a gamblin man Jack not
anymore
once a gambling man always a gambling
man a professional thief with 40 million
dollars in debt and his family's life on
the line must commit one final heist rob
a futuristic airborne casino filled with
the world's most dangerous criminals the
film stars Adam Copeland Kelsey Grammer
and Denise Richards oh she's from Wild
Things I urged myself alright that's it
for today but leave us a comment and let
us know if you'll be watching first cow
or money plane I'm Kayla mana mmus and
I'll see you next time